[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to game six
of the world church championship match
2021 between magnus carlton and yanni
published the first five games ended in
a draw and now we have game six games
six has a tendency to be the most
interesting one in any wheelchair
championship match if you uh guys
remember that tal versus botvinnik game
six where tao had that brilliant night
sacrifice on f4 or uh fischer versus
spassky uh known as the applause maybe
in modern times so game six always has a
nice ring to it and this is game six of
this match so let's see what happened in
this one uh but very quickly let's check
out uh
we have these uh a couple of nice photos
here you can see uh the playing hall uh
of course there will not be that many
people when uh the game is actually
played everyone will leave uh and then
only maybe uh the official photographer
will be able to walk around and do some
photos
and here you can see regarding the
handshake that here we finally have a
eye contact and the one would expect no
less from game six and you can see how
tense maurice is as this is the first
eye contact we've had in the match so
far and also i don't know who made the
first move i was the gentleman on the
left you you guys can see him right now
but if any of you know who he is do
share in the comments uh the move on the
board is e4 even though that's not the
move that's going to be played in the
game but both magnus and nipple seem to
be having a great time
laughing at this e4 move uh sort of
saying that yeah there's no way magnus
plays e4 for the for the rest of the uh
tournament uh so that being said let's
check it out it's uh it's a beautiful
game it's the longest ever wheelchair
championship game so maybe if you don't
have like 20 minutes or maybe you know
40 minutes i don't know how long it will
take me uh to make this um
maybe watch it some other time but now
let's check it out magnus with the white
pieces opens with d4
we have knight to f6 by nipple knight to
f3 d5 and now there are a couple of well
not a couple there are a lot of good
options here you could play c4 you could
play e3 uh you could play uh a bishop to
forgo for some sort of a london setup
but magnus plays g3 and it's not that
it's a new move or anything like that
but it's just
not nearly as popular as the ones that
we've discussed uh nipple goes e6 even
though you could play a lot of things
here like c6 c5 you know
anything pretty much can be played here
and nepal decides to go for e6 this uh
no not travis but this prevents him from
developing his light square bishop uh
but he knows what he's doing we have
bishop to g2 bishop to e7 and the both
players just castle so castles castles
and now not c4 as this is the the common
move here but rather b3 so magnus fiance
the one bishop now he wants the fiance
the other bishop as well uh and nepo
says all right now it's time to strike
in the center uh he pushes c5 so one
would again expect bishop to be two but
magnus just plays d characters in c5 we
have bishop captures and now again not
bishop to b2 as one would expect but uh
the immediate c4 and this is now
a new move so already as of move eight
we have a completely new game uh but not
really there is a game in the database
that uh had this position but you know
you have to search uh you know far in
the uh you know uh crazy parts of the
internet to find such games but okay we
have c4 now asking nipple do you wanna
capture maybe on c4 and of course uh
it's um
it's a good it's a good question because
how will white react to this will he
play b captures on c4 and
have an isolated c pawn or is it is it
maybe a pawn sacrifice and you could
just ignore this play bishop to beat you
could play bishop to a3 of course uh
first we have uh d captures on c4 by
nipple uh also very interesting was d4
maybe uh d4 then the idea is a3 with b4
and if a5 preventing b4 then we can play
bishop to b2 and you can see why it has
a lot of pressure on this d for pawn so
knight c6 defending let's say b for now
and now you want to take away one of the
defenders of the d4 pawn so maybe
captures captures we're going to see
rook captures on a1 bishop captures and
now bishop or knight will capture on b4
let's say bishop captures knight
captures on d4 and the game continues uh
but uh you know uh if you if you look at
the position the material is equal but
magnus has this bishop and this bishop
and nepo has this bishop which is nice
but this bishop not doing all that much
so it's uh
definitely controlling more space so
nipple not interested in uh
pushing the pawn he plays d captures on
c4 and now uh there is a game where b
captures on c2 was played it's from the
it's from 1995 uh between uh
and ulf von herman
where black won after white captured the
the c4 pawn but here magnus plays queen
to c2 and this is the actual new move so
already as of uh move nine we have a
completely new game and now nepal says
all right i'm not interested in some uh
in grabbing more material here of course
you can't capture right away because the
bishop is hanging first nipple defends
it
and now after knight beat to d2 he says
i'm not interested in grabbing material
because you could capture on b3 let's
say knight captures on b3 with a double
attack on the bishop bishop can now move
somewhere let's say bishop a3 now knight
e5 and white's position is again very
very active for example knight b to d7
we can play knight to c4
attack the bishop here and let's say it
captures rook captures uh on c1 and the
white has uh well a whole lot of
pressure on the position uh nipple not
interested in facing this so here he
plays knight to c6 and the magnus spent
really no time maybe three minutes up
until this point and nipple already
spent half an hour on his clock because
you have to figure all of this out so
here we have knight captures on c4
magnus finally grabs back the pawn and
b5 now again nepo spent some time on
this but uh it's a question what do you
do with the knight uh there is a crazy
crazy variation with bishop to beat you
you just say okay grab my knight and
after the knight is captured knight to
g5 saying that now okay we're gonna
capture here and then threaten checkmate
but also your c6 knight is hanging and
here we would go into a for kind of a
forced variation bishop to d4 we're
gonna play bishop captures on c6 attack
the rook we're going to capture on b2
attack the real queen captures here
we're going to play bishop to b7 and
after all is said and done let's say
captures captures and rook after c1
let's say captures captures now you you
didn't really achieve all that much
merely you've helped the black develop
his pieces so
magnus is not interested in going for
that he just goes knight to e5 uh and
now we have knight to b4 as the bishop
and knight here are targets so you
target the white queen queen to b2 and
now bishop to b7 and it seems nipple
also developed his pieces quite nicely
so what can magnus do here he starts
with a3 he wants to get rid of this
knight and now we have knight uh back to
c6 knight to d5 is also very interesting
uh but then we get something like maybe
knight to d3 we attack the bishop bishop
to b6 and now knight to e5
and uh it's uh well it's just a very
interesting position for example knight
after d7 we're gonna attack the knight
here and now we can sort of trade
everything captures capture so let's say
a4 uh b captures rook captures and you
get this position but um
it's it's not much
if anything the the bishop fare here is
very very nicely placed uh but again
nipple not interested in that he goes
knight to c6 now puts pressure on the e5
knight and knight back to d3 now uh
attacking the bishop here uh we have
bishop back to b6 and now comes bishop
to g5 so pinning the knight and
basically saying i can double your pawns
here whenever i want to uh
regardless of uh you know whether you
trade queens or not so nepal played rook
f to d8 fairly quickly and now while
magnus could continue in the same way
rook fd1 maybe we'll see rook ac8 rook 8
to c1 uh magnus trades on on f6 so
bishop captures on f6 and now we have g
captures on f6 he decides to keep the
queens on the board as um uh he he's not
all that impressed with uh any attacking
opportunities magnus might have here
just because of the semi-open g file so
rook 8 to c1 and now knight to d4 just
to trade uh some of the pieces you can
trade the knight here you can trade the
light square bishop and then uh well
you're just gonna claim that white
didn't really achieve anything out of
the opening here so knight captures on
d4 we have bishop captures on d4 and now
you can't really move away uh from the
defense of the a3 pawn the black queen
still attacks that font so queen to a2
now bishop captures some g2 king
captures and queen to b7 check nipple
uses some nice queen maneuvering to
centralize the queen via the e4 square
so king g1 we have queen to e4 and now
magnus has to bring the queen back into
the game we have queen to c2 and now the
question is do you go rook a to c8 or or
maybe
you want to improve the position a
little bit further so if rook hc8 magnus
probably just captures this for example
rook captures rook captures after king
to g7 rook will go back to c2 and it's a
position very similar to what actually
happened in the game but uh
uh nipple feels that uh he he still
should improve the position a little bit
so he plays a5 and now uh you can play
e3 right away even though you want to
play e3 the problem with e3 right away
is just bishop captures an e3 and now
the knight is hanging here and you lost
the pawn for nothing so magnus first has
to increase um
the the defense of the d3 square so rook
after d1 and now we have king to g7 by
nipple
a much
more uh
well sort of a prudent idea might have
been something like f5 uh just clearing
the dark squares for the bishop here and
now if you if you play something like e3
uh just bishop back to f6 or if you try
something else um you know it's uh for
example queen to d2 might try and start
some trouble here we can even play f4
even that is in the position so f5 is a
very interesting move if queen
characters on f4 we can capture on e2 so
very very nicely done but okay never
plays
king to g7 and now we have rook to d2
magnus spent a lot of time on this mode
we're only at move 25
and magnus is already down to 23 minutes
on the clock whereas nipple has some 37
minutes on the clock and we still need
to play 15 more moves to reach time
control
but magnus decided against e3
for a couple of reasons
well it's hard to say why but the if we
repeat the the rook eight the c8 line
queen captures rook captures and rook
captures now maybe queen to f3 putting
pressure on the rook here or let's say
rook to c1 now queen to f5 putting
pressure on the under knight and now
maybe we see sort of a repetition here
or maybe something like that so maybe
magnus wanted to avoid uh
such a thing but the interesting thing
is that after uh e3 you could also just
play bishop to e5 and now after
something like queen to e2 maybe even h5
so that even that is in the position
let's say knight captures an e5 queen
captures and now queen to f3 uh very
very nicely done but uh you know it's um
so very very equal that it's hard to
pinpoint what's better so instead
african to g7 we have rook to d2 magnus
not pushing for anything you know to
happen rapidly he just wants to slowly
uh but you know surely uh get more and
more out of the position uh give me a
second i think meadow wants to join us
[Music]
yeah he he knocks on the door and then
he you know just go goes into the other
room uh so after rook the d2 uh we have
finally rook eight to c8 by nipple uh
there was also a lot of talk about a
very interesting move i'm sure you guys
know which movie that is and that is b4
point is after eight captures on b4 and
eight captures on b4 you don't really
have the option of knight captures on b4
i mean you do
but then you run into bishop captures
and have to czech king captures and
queen captures on b4 and uh well let's
say rook after san diego capture 78
it's equal material and the white does
have the past b pawn but
the black king is somewhat safer the
white king has
much less in in front of him and it
would be well it was wouldn't be all
that pleasant so what you would probably
have to do after b4 is captures captures
but not capture with the knight but
other than this what is there there's
this tricky knight the c5 move where we
would probably see a queen trade queen
captures and c2 rook captures and c2 now
bishop captures in c5 rook captures and
c5 and sort of have this end game here
but
uh you know for example rook to a3 goes
after the pawn rook b5 we're going to
see rook captures on b3 and then at some
point white will go after this pawn it's
very unlikely that black will be able to
do anything so while b4 is strong
doesn't uh
well yield more than more than equal
game so here rook eight to c8 nepal says
all right if you want to part with your
queen i'm very interested in playing
that and magnus goes for it we have
queen captures on c8 rook captures rook
captures and now queen to d5 going after
the b3 pawn so kind of forcing magnus to
play b4 which he does we have b4 a4 and
now luckily for nipple he locked cross
and spawns on dark squares he has a dark
square bishop so if he can go after them
that's going to be that's going to be
great and now finally magnus plays e3
which wasn't easy he's down to nine
minutes and the clock nipple has over
half an hour uh and still 11 moves to be
made to reach time control and here we
have bishop to e5
very interesting was bishop to beat you
because if you capture with the rook you
lose the knight if you capture with the
knight you lose the rook uh and then we
would see something like rook the c5
attacking the queen and only after the
queen moves now rook captures on b2
queen captures on d3 and now uh let's
say rook b to c2 for example queen
captures an a3 rook captures on b5 and
now let's say queen dave a1 check king
g2 uh queen to b1 attacking the rook now
rook to c3 with a very very equal play
so instead of this we have bishop to e5
saying okay you still can't go anywhere
because the rook would be hanging and
now
magnus played h4 and this took a lot of
time magnus is now down to six minutes
but just to show you why magnus play
played h4 and why he had to spend so
much time on this uh it's uh because uh
well if he just goes to rook to c5 for
example with the idea of uh
everything that's going to happen let's
say queen b3 we capture an e5f captures
on e5 and now rook to d7 with ideas of
doubling up here and doing some damage
along the seventh rank queen captures on
a3 we're gonna play rook to c7 and now
let's say h5 we don't want to get
checkmated rook captures on f7 check
king g6 king the g2 and now queen
captures on b4 we're gonna play rook g7
check king to h6 rook to h7 check king g
not king g5 we're gonna play king g6 and
you really don't have um a way of uh you
know just the finishing of the black
king because he can always hide here
so you will probably have to do
something like this and
repeat so magnus wants to ensure that
he
sort of has a firmer grip on the
position before he goes into something
like this and he starts with h4 so now
if we repeat all of that at least we've
taken away one more square from the
black king after the attack starts uh
nipple starts of course also with h5 he
he wants to prevent any more pawn pushes
here and the king to h2 so just uh a
safety move with the king sort of saying
it might win a tempo in the future
because there will be no queen to d1
check or something and the magnus is now
down to three minutes on the clock uh
and nipple plays uh bishop
to b2 and he goes after the pawn here
but now is uh is a very very interesting
moment because magnus instantly plays
rook to c5 attacking the queen queen to
d6 and now is a critical moment in the
game uh where magnus actually has a
winning position but but it's such a
difficult move to see
uh that you guys will enjoy it if you
find it you know it's going to improve
your day greatly so feel free to pause
the video here and try to spot the
winning move for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on you know seeing
beyond the depth 40 and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show the move
is rook seat the c2 that's the good
stuff and it's uh now now that you think
about it of course the move makes
perfect sense because we can't capture
the
bishop because the knight hands we can't
capture with the knight because the rook
hangs by moving the rook to c2 now
capturing the bishop is a threat and you
can't just ignore the a3 pawn if you go
bishop back to e5 we're going to play f4
and now bishop back to for example a1
we're going to play knight c5 force the
queen back and after the queen moves
just rook c1 black loses the bishop
that's it so what would happen after
rook c to c2 something like bishop
captures on a3 and now we're gonna play
knight to f4 that's the the reason now
we control uh both c and the d file
we're threatening to pick up the the h5
pawn but that's the least of black's
concerns for example queen captures on
b4 we're gonna play rook to d7 now we
threaten even knight captures on e6 so
probably queen to b1 uh putting pressure
on the on the rook here rook c to c7
we're of course going to do a nice rook
lift uh king to g8 and now let's say
rook the c8 with check and there's
really not much more you can do if you
go back we're going to start attacking
and if you block with the bishop then
even something like this to finish the
job black of course would not surrender
here he would defend because even if you
capture and traded everything the two
past pawns will be winning uh so of
course you're gonna improve the position
a little bit first knight e3 let's say
queen e7 we're gonna further attack the
queen queen d6 works cd8 queen goes back
and now king to g2 we improve the
position of our king and only after
black tries to escape now we capture and
that's it after black captures uh well
we just play king f3 and we have a
completely winning end game uh the the
black pawns will not be a problem the
white knight can prevent them from going
anywhere and then it's just a four
against four on the king side which of
course it's easily winning since we we
have an extra night so uh rook c the c2
uh was missed by both of them and uh i
think magnus will be very very much
surprised when he hears about this after
the game maybe even in the press
conference i don't know if they actually
warned them about opportunities missed
in the press conferences but um you know
i think after
some eight hours of play
as much as this game lost that i don't
think they'd uh you know appreciate it
all that much uh but okay here uh we
have rook back to d1 now this is a
thread because then the knight will be
guarding the rook and nipple captures on
a3 bishop captures on a3 uh we have rook
captures on b5 and now queen to d7
attacking carlson's rook here so rook
back to c5 and now uh we have pawn to e5
interestingly nipple nothing doesn't
capture this bishop on b4 move on b4 and
there was a lot of talk about this how
pretty much everyone would do this
except nepal that's why nipple is so
dangerous because he doesn't do what
most people would do
of course the knight cannot capture
uh the rook would still be hanging here
so we will probably see rogue back to c1
and then bishop to a5 and now it seems
like uh you know it's not all that much
it's you know how are you going to keep
an eye on this pawn for example knight
f4 attacks the queen we're going to play
queen to b5 now and after rook to b1
we're gonna play queen to f5 so there
are a lot of uh good ideas to be to be
played here for example rook b7 we're
going to play e5 chase away the knight
and after something like knight h3 we're
gonna play queen to c2 and if this pawn
starts rolling up down the board uh it's
not going to be easy to stop him so
bishop captures some b for definitely an
idea but nipple first wants to prevent
knight to f4 also uh
you know has uh has merit
and now we have rook back to c2 by
magnus e4 is one idea but he doesn't
mind uh e4 by bayan because then again
the f4 square is being freed for the
knight so here we have rook back to c2
uh and uh now comes uh well queen to d5
again uh capturing the pawn on b4 is
perfectly fine but for some reason nepo
decides against it
we have queen to d5 now uh and uh well
what do you play here queen to b3 could
be very very annoying
here we have rook d to d2 now you don't
have to worry about anything hanging we
have queen to b3 and now we have rook to
a2 and now magnus is down to 30 seconds
on the clock and remember there is no
increment before move 60 so he has 30
seconds for his two next moves and nepo
has to be very very well precise in this
position uh so what you could go for is
f5 f5 is definitely a move uh you could
play but then it's very very easy for
magnus to reach time control he will
just you know repeat to rotate the c2
and now after bishop captures knight
captures we're gonna see queen captures
on b4 and this is a you know a dead draw
so i think what happened here is that uh
nipple was trying to play on carlson's
time and after rook to a2 he played e4
sort of a tricky move magnus has to make
two more moves
to reach the first time control uh but
now magnus plays knight to c5 and there
really was no surprise there uh queen
captures on b4 and now knight captures
ani for saying okay you can have my
knight i'm gonna capture the the bishop
here uh so here
uh mu 40 has been played and magnus
reached it with six seconds on the clock
and now nipple plays a queen to b3 with
some five seconds on the clock so they
both uh you know played it uh as much as
they could uh but there was the very
interesting move instead of knight
captures on e4 there was the incredible
rook d to c2 which leaves black
basically without a move it's not it's
not a real tube swung
because um well you can play f5 but
other than this there there really is no
good move and we will probably see
something like this five knight captures
on a4 and after queen captures on a4
rook c3 the bishop cannot move and after
queen moves anywhere we're going to
capture this um
pawn here and now we'd have two rooks
against the queen with a better position
for white and here carlson would be
would be definitely pushing for a win uh
but in the game knight characters and e4
was played and okay queen to b3 now uh
what do you play here uh we have rook 8
to c2 now time control has been reached
both of them were granted an additional
hour and now bishop back to f8 uh
preparing to
push that pawn and the bishop guards the
a3 square so the pawn will be very happy
there
here we have knight to c5
uh attacking the queen again
if you go for rook the c7 uh right away
then a3 can be very dangerous you've
broke the d7a2 and you don't really have
anything here even if you capture we can
we can simply give up the queen we don't
care and again you're not stopping that
past pawn so instead we have knight to
c5 magnus again wants to trade this
knight for for for that strong bishop uh
but nip of course just moves the queen
we have knight back to d3 and now a3 and
now this pawn will be very very safe
here well uh at least for for a very
long time uh knight to f4 finally the
knight reaches its destination uh nipple
does not have an e pawn or a g pawn so
you can never kick it away and you have
to be very careful here we have queen to
a5 uh just you know keeping an eye on
that pawn and not allowing any rook
lifts then maybe this rook would hang
if any of the rook leaves the second
rank then you can also advance the past
pawn so the rooks for the moment are
stuck here guarding the a2 square
rook to a2 by magnus now comes bishop to
b4 attacking the rook and now rook to d3
very interesting is rook to d5 because
it also goes after the h5 pawn the
problem is after queen a4 this is a
threat you don't have time to go after
that pawn even even if you do this with
check king moves we're gonna play knight
captures on f6 queen b3 is just too
strong the rook will move you will play
queen b2 push the pawn and win the game
or you know have a really really
uh make life miserable for for white so
instead after bishop to b4 we have rook
to d3
and now we have king to h6 by nipple uh
interestingly bishop to c3 kind of you
know ends the game uh because after
let's say a check king to h7 or
something now back to f4 we can play
bishop to b2 trapping that rook on a2
and at some point you will have to
give it up but nipple doesn't like his
chances if he does this uh because it
will be only magnus who could play who
can play for the win black of course has
a draw but only if he plays a million
perfect moves in a row so of course uh
he he doesn't want to go into that
voluntarily so instead we have king to
h6 here just you know adding another
defender to this pawn and now rook back
to d1
we have queen to a4 attacking the rook
here and now comes rook d to a1 and now
magnus is saying all right you've had
your fun with the a3 pawn now this
knight is coming um
uh
to help out with the attack of that uh
of that
pawn and we're gonna put it somewhere
let's say maybe on c2 to attack it or on
c4 and we want to win that pawn so
bishop to d6 trying to go for some
tricky ideas now comes king to g1 and
now uh queen to b3 you don't want to
capture this if you capture this it's
really not a problem for white it's
again black will be suffering for the
rest of the game so instead the queen b3
was played now with some um uh well a
lot of pressure on on these spawns you
have to be very careful knights the e2
and then now comes queen to d3 puts
pressure on the knight here so knight to
d4 and now we have king back to h7 not
allowing the
knights to be in range of delivering
some sort of a check here
and if bishop captures on g3 this is
very important you do not win anything
with captures captures which check wins
the knight because of this rook captures
an a3 that's very annoying and now you
don't have anything here you're gonna
have to give up the bishop for a pawn
and that's it so instead after knight
the d4 king back to h7 and now king the
h2 by magnus still waiting with the
remaneuvering of the knight uh just a
little bit uh queen to e4 and now comes
finally rook captures an a3 so we're
gonna capture it with the rook if you're
wondering uh why
not just go knight to c2 and pick up the
pawn well we're gonna play queen to b3
and now if knight captures on a3 there's
bishop to e5 so you know this would be
this would be lost for white so you
can't really pick it up with the with
the knight like ever uh so instead we
have king to h2 and now we have a queen
to e4
we have rook captures on a3
there's no other way to continue the
game or to try to push for something
with white uh but it also means giving
up the h4 pawn as uh well uh the the g
pawn will not be able to capture so here
first the queen captures an h4 check
king the g1 and now queen to e4
so not interested in in uh giving up the
exchange because well that's just uh
endless torture uh so here we have rook
to a4 and now comes uh bishop to e5 uh
interestingly bishop captures in g3 with
the idea that if
this is captured uh you can capture the
e3 pawn just loses the knights the e2
attacks the bishop also puts pressure on
the queen so that's just the game so
after rook a4 we have bishop the e5 uh
and there really are no good discoveries
here even though you have some pressure
so knights to e2 uh it's it's a
discovery but you know nothing is really
being threatened queen to c2 now rook uh
one to a two attacks the queen queen b3
and the king the g2 now so magnus has to
figure out if if there even is a way for
him to start pushing for something here
we have queen to d5 and now uh how do
you continue whether something like king
to h2 uh you are in check magnus place
f3 and this does uh
give nipples some extra chances of of uh
checking the white king
but it does seem to be the only way to
to make progress here and here we have
queen to d1 uh so you allowed uh
you know some some draft here around the
white king black will of course try and
take advantage of this
and uh both are now only one move uh to
reach the second time control and after
move 60 they are granted additional 15
minutes plus you start gaining
additional time with every move you get
30 seconds on the clock so here we have
f4 by magnus he starts uh with an attack
on the bishop bishop to c7 and now king
to f2 uh interestingly rook to a7
although uh looking very appealing after
something like bishop to b6 rook
captures an f7 king g6 uh is uh
winning for black because uh well your
rook is attacked but also just queen to
d5 check
and you can't prevent both of your rooks
from uh
from being lost and of course the rook
here is impossible the bishop covers
this square so that would be a problem
so after bishop to c7 we have king to f2
you know just keeping everything safe
and now bishop to b6 putting pressure on
this weak e3 pawn we have rooked a1
chasing the queen away queen to b3 and
now rook to e4
uh magnus uh has that has to figure out
how to make progress here and this is uh
one uh one way to do it so here we have
king to g7 now comes rook to e8 we have
f5 by nipple uh and now rook eight a8
preparing to create some uh well checks
along the back rank queen to b4 uh and
now comes rook a to c8 we have bishop to
a5 now going after this queen to a1
check move and you can't really allow
this so magnus has to go back rook to c1
brush it back to b6 and now rook to e5
going after this f5 pawn but queen to b3
it's interesting how this queen to b3
move always solves everything for nipple
and
you can't really go after this uh f5
pawn because then bishop captures an e3
check uh well yeah you can't uh leave
the e3 pawn on defend it so here we have
rook back to e8 queen to d5 and now rook
c to c8 but now queen to h1 now the h1
square has been made available for the
queen and what can magnus do now so you
could give one check but after king to
f6 there's really no way to make
progress here for example uh rook here
check king to f6 you you can't even
deliver this check to try and win the
bishop the queen covers the c6 square so
it's not all that much so we have rook
back to c1 attacks the queen queen goes
back and now uh rook to b1 by magnus
attacking the bishop here we have bishop
to a7 uh interestingly uh h4 here is
pretty deadly for black uh it's a sort
of a move that kind of forces you to
really think because the bishop is
attacked but also the h pawn can be very
deadly uh but it's sort of an instant
draw h3 and if something like rook b to
b8 we're going to play queen to g2 with
check king e1 h2 and now you can't hope
to get anything out of this game with
white rook the g8 checking f6 rook the
b6 check uh we can even play king to e7
you you really don't care and now you
have to stop the the past pawn so we're
gonna sacrifice here capture this play
king f2 and this will be
well this will be fine but uh okay in
the game bishop to a7 he just gets the
bishop out of harms away and rook to e7
now uh adding more pressure to the
bishop we have bishop to c5 attacking
the rook and only now rook to e5
attacking the queen uh when the queen
moves the bishop but also still this f5
pawn so queen to d3 attacking the rook
on b1 now comes rook to b7
uh and uh queen to c2 now so uh what can
you do here we have rook to b5 now a
double attack on the bishop butcher back
to a7 and now rook to a5 so going after
the bishop bishop to b6 we have rook a
to b5 and bishop to a7 and now only now
we have rook captures on f5 uh so uh the
the the pawn has been one we have queen
to d3 now putting pressure on this uh
pawn here and how do you defend it well
uh you could do some sort of a passive
defense but magnus decides to go for a
very active one uh rook captures on f7
he said all right i'm tired with of this
bishop you know controlling the game uh
all this time uh let's just uh trade it
for a rook so king captures and rooked a
b7 check king to g6 and now rook
captures on a7 and now we have this
position where it's three pawns against
one rook and knight against the queen so
can magnus do something here well if he
can set up some sort of a
you know teamwork effort where he can
start pushing these pawns then yes if no
then no so here we have queen to d5
nipple still ready to bring his queen
over to h1 to do some
damage with a rook to a6 check king to
h7 now of course uh you could go
in front here but it looks a little bit
dangerous so maybe just go back uh rook
to a1 not allowing the queen to h1 and
now came to g6 we have knights to d4 and
now queen to b7 we have rook to eight
you're not even allowing queen to b2
because of course you do not want to
allow any counter play queen to h1 and
now we have rook to a6 check king to f7
and not knight to f3 the knight is
excellently placed here because it
prevents queen h2 check so the queen can
now go somewhere else queen b1 and now
rook to d6 now magnus might be thinking
of something like rook d2 rook e2 and
then we are gonna put the rook behind
the pass pawn and start pushing it so
king g7 and now rook to d5 attacking the
pawn here but it's sort of a tricky idea
just uh magnus just wants to play rook
to d2 with tempo so here we have queen
a2 uh
attacking the rook here and only now
rook to d2 attacking the queen queen to
b1 and now uh rook to e2 and now you are
ready to start pushing this pawn but
nipple prevents it queen to b6 so you're
not pushing the pawn now and it's um
very tricky if you just move the king
let's say you want to start pushing the
pawn we're going to play some like king
f6 and now even if you start pushing
it's not all that easy for example queen
b3 e5 checking f7 we're going to play e6
check and after king e7 f5 uh how are
you pushing any further after let's say
queen b5 it's not uh it's not all that
easy the pawn is hanging here rook to e5
we're gonna play queen b to check let's
say king h3 queen to f2 and uh it's very
unlikely that you will be able to get
out of this the pawn covers g4 the queen
here is very very annoying so now you
can start pushing but it's not all that
clear how so here we have rook back to
c2 by magnus and the queen to b1
we have knights to d for now now magnus
decides on a different setup another
this standard one with the rook behind
the pass spawn uh well we require a
modern one we have queen to h1 now comes
rook to c7 check king of six rook the c6
check king to f7 and now knight back to
f3 we're not allowing the queen to
harass us queen back to b1 and now we
have knight the g5 check king g7 uh
knights the e60 king to f7 and now
knights to d4 so we've reached move 100
uh but that's still not the longest
world chess championship game ever
played we still have to make some uh 24
moves to reach that queen to h1 putting
pressure on the rook here so rook the c7
check king to f6 now knight back to f3
again
uh saying you have to
you have to figure out something else
this is just not going to work magnus so
queen back to b1 and now rook to d7 uh
we have queen to b to check rook to d2
again now we have to go back queen to b1
we have knight to g1 now uh so how do
you how do you continue here queen to b4
we attacked the rook now comes rook to
d1 queen to b3 and now rook to d6 king
g7 now rook to d4 and now we are slowly
making progress here uh as the e4 pawn
is uh soon starting to to go forward we
have queen to be to check knights to e2
now guarding the rook and now we can
finally start pushing this maybe a
little bit better
than with the rook on e2 so here queen
to b1 and finally we have e4 everything
is nicely protected we can't uh
uh
allow allow black to capture anything so
here we have queen to h1 and not the g1
obviously queen to h1 airport is
preparing this h h4 move which will
allow him to start checking magnus's
king as well uh so here rook the d7
check and now we have king to g8
uh the situation on the clock is one
minute for magnus and some three and a
half minutes for nipple
but they do get 30 seconds increment per
move so it's not all that scary uh rook
back to d4 and now uh queen to h to
check you could start with h4 first but
queen to hd check is also fine king e3
we have h4 and now uh captures on h4
queen h3 check king d2 and now queen
captures on h4 so now uh magnus has
improved his position a little bit but
the king is now a little more wide open
and the queen will be able to check and
so rook to d3
we have king to f8 we have rook to f3
now comes queen to d8 with check king to
e3 and now queen to a5 we have queen
king to f2 magnus has to hide his king
as well as possible before he starts
pushing queen to a7 check rook to e3 now
uh queen to d7 and now uh knight the g3
so still waiting with uh pushing of the
pawns uh we have queen to d2 with check
king of three queen to d1 check rook to
e2 and now queen to b3 check
uh we have king to g2 and now queen to
b7 again pinning the pawn so you can
start pushing its the e5 and now comes
rook to d2 and with this rook to d2
we've reached move 125 and this is now
the longest world chess championship
game ever played uh taking the spot of
that game five uh from the 1978 match
between anatoly uh between uh viktor
korchner and anali karpov uh that was uh
well ended in a draw but it was a very
very impressive one uh so here after
this uh a move we have rook to d2 and
now queen to b3
right we have rook back to d5 now comes
king the e7 rook the e5 check king to f7
and now rook to f5 check we have king to
e8 and only now e5 uh magnus has
created an outpost for this rook on f6
and this is how he wants to play it and
bring the king over here uh via via the
king's side so queen to a2 check we have
king to h3 and now uh the thing is you
have to
keep your queen behind the white king so
queen the queen to be three queen to b1
queen to c2 that's what you want to play
here but nipple played queen to e6 here
and this is a problem uh because this is
now a table-based win for magnus if he
can play it uh
uh well at the perfection uh but you
know it's it's not easy defending this
you only have a queen and this can be so
annoying and boring to
try to try and hold this for for eight
nine hours who knows how long they
played uh but now it's definitely a
winning position for magnus so here we
have king to h4 queen to h6 check knight
the h5 and you can't really stop white's
progress here we have queen to h7 and
now feel free to pause the video and win
the game for white while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not moving the
rook or delivering check and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the movies of course e6 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you uh have just uh won a classical
game uh the first one ever since uh the
2016 match between magnus in uh sergey
karjakin in in new york uh the problem
is the rook cannot be captured because
knight the g7 check picks up the queen
so of course we can't have that and
after something like this this of course
will be a completely winning end game
for white so after e6 we have queen to
g6 by nipple but now rook to f7
there is no move you can make here king
to d8 and now even f5 attacking the
queen we have queen to g1 and now uh you
have to be very careful if you play
something like f6 which looks like a
move you really want to make then uh you
will allow uh well black to just draw
the game like the queen d4 check king g5
queen e5 check you lose this pawn and
you're no longer gonna win this game but
magnus founded the nicest way to end it
he played knight to g7 and he was in
this position on move
136 that janipomishi of russia resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the point is carlson uh
created sort of a barrier here and he
will hide his king on g8
uh play f6 e7 and that's it if you guys
are interested we can even show it let's
say king g5 queen g3 checking it [ __ ]
queen h4 we're going to go here and
after one more check we're going to go
king h7 now hide the king here and
that's it whatever black plays and black
only has a queen it's really not fun f6
or whatever
e7 e8 and that's it it's game over so of
course after knight to g7 ian sodis he
uh congratulated magnus he resigned in
the game and we have a first decisive
classical game uh and uh well what uh
what a fitting end uh it is for it to be
game six as every world championships uh
well yeah the most beautiful game uh
often is a game six
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it sorry for a bit of a
longer video but uh i mean it's
completely crazy you could make like a
like a 10 hour hour video of this game
you could make like a video marathon of
this game so i hope you guys enjoyed it
i did not show like every line i only
showed the the ones that i thought were
the most interesting so hope you don't
mind i explored a few more uh but yeah
that's it hope you enjoyed it uh game
seven uh coming up next uh as soon as
they played because this one you know
lasted so long that the next one is is
like starting uh in a few hours
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank matthew
hilscher andreas sean paul williams mark
benson and san cotsolo for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
wheelchair championship
until it ends thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day